foreign
not a traditional life right not now
right not now there you go but I would
say before this I was good in my
professional world yeah you're great in
your professional world right good what
we did
and then this other thing happens and
there's a perception that
um if you are a mom who's a counselor in
a local community and you work 60 hours
a week and you've got two kids and
you're exhausted and your husband had
helped that much but he's trying and
it's you're just making it right and you
are a plumber and you got four plumbers
that work for you and you have a small
little business and you've got two kids
one little league and you're trying to
coach two right yeah there's this at
life we're running right yeah the
illusion is if I can just get here if I
if this would just happen if I could get
this dollar amount yeah the whole thing
is ah yeah right then I can finally fill
in the blank yeah and I've come to
wrestle with over the last few years
especially
that if then thing is a
it's a myth I knew that psychologically
if you'd come to see me like as a client
or just like yeah like I would have told
you that like that's not true but I
believed it it's so funny you mentioned
that like I'm like maybe this was maybe
three weeks ago talking with my wife and
she's we're at the kitchen an island and
she puts her hands down and goes I just
I'm ready for
life to just slow down I'm just I'm
ready for this to happen this to happen
and these things you know in life is
going to slow down
and I looked at her I said this is life
I said this is it I said this feeling
this this this is what it is it's never
going to slow down there's always going
to be something like you just need to
enjoy this is exactly what I told her
you just need to enjoy the present of
where we are at any time because there
is no nothing to chase I mean there's no
there's not going to be a well as soon
as we get over this hill we're going to
Coast yeah if you got kids if you got
you know for your family it's it's
constant yeah it's on it's on and it's
on from the beginning to to the end but
yeah I was like this is it yeah that's
what I told her it's like this is it
there's no there's no we get here and
it's going to slow down well and when
you see that
okay here's the Calendar's got some
space in it that's when your kid breaks
their arm if that's when the teacher
calls and says your kid just said called
somebody a such and such and you're like
my kid right it doesn't stop yeah that
one weekend that you're like oh we have
it free and that's when somebody in your
family gets sick that's right yeah and
or your buddy calls and like hey I need
a lawyer right now right okay here we go
yeah right yeah or something uh you have
a like we had a major storm power goes
out for like three days oh okay I guess
we won't be going anywhere because
y'all's Texas power grids helping
together with duct tape yeah string yeah
yeah and WD-40
um so how has even in a limited time
going and sitting across from somebody
a mental health professional and saying
I'm not all right and beyond that not
just the act of going to counseling but
for a guy that had all the answers yeah
and not only had all the answers but
people hire you for your answers right
and you are a very particular type of
assassin
to be able to sit in that with that
skill set and go that doesn't serve me
here right
I need help here yes how has that
impacted you being a husband how's that
impacted you being a dad because I would
say arguably those are not arguably
those are the most important roles the
head of lawyer ahead of yeah Tick Tock
sensation but I know that
what it has taught me is
my mind can tell me pretty much anything
that I want to know and what I want to
say my mind is like
it's it's it's very surgical in the way
it will help me control my reactions and
responses but it is a terrible doctor of
diagnosing what's going on in my body
and I've always been the type when and
you know this when you're in high
conflict situations your mind is what
matters like your mind is what keeps you
sharp I have to be listening to every
word that they say
but my body
my mind's gonna get out of here just hey
no no no yeah you're you're
not relevant right now I need your mind
and it's as Vandercook says it's keeping
the score right oh yeah yeah yeah
every day and that's what shut down and
so having these like deep dives into
where that's coming from and where I
found that was and I don't mind sharing
it was a just a sense of
being alone
and I say that because at the time you
and I weren't connected
um and
nobody in my world could like relate to
what was happening in that space at the
same time it's I'm very just it's a it's
a privilege to even use the applications
they could inflict if Instagram wanted
to they could ban me and kick me off
tomorrow I have no free speech right
right there just they're like thanks for
using our app you know what I mean
making us a bunch of AD money yeah yeah
that's it and
the
the continuous
tense that I that I live in you I could
tell myself you're good oh you're fine
just and I realized I was not giving
myself a lot of that
attention and permission as therapists
like to say give us a lot of permission
I remember being like permission or what
yeah like I didn't like that where I was
like can we not use that word
it turns out I was just
that was just Pride you know or you were
deposing yourself yeah yeah yeah so she
was she was uh been great at when so you
realize you you do have a mind you do
have a body and your body is what is
suffering
um and you're not giving attention to
that and that's been that's been great
and and since then I've been it's made
me a better father to your question it's
maybe a better husband and that I'm
taking better care of my selfie actually
you know what you could probably go to
bed yeah how much of that is the answer
so many times that you know what calling
a friend and going to bed yeah yeah how
about you you're working out let's throw
a sleep yeah you know what I mean
because you probably need that yeah and
that's and that's my evenings it's
either I need to have a conversation
with my wife to check in rather than us
just both going to bed I need to go to
sleep or I need to go work out and you
know work out that anxiety or whatever
yeah it's not like there's a Blog that
is part of our education yes and wasn't
like somebody just said hey read this
book you're gonna have a
a bad crisis here in a little bit you
did have if I remember correctly an
extraordinary dean of students that
tried to tell you some of this stuff but
yeah he was a real pain but
God's the worst yeah yeah at that time
we weren't ready enough I mean I wasn't
either man yeah well I mean even even as
a student like so many times of like man
if I went back to that class I'd learned
so much it was I think in different
parts of her life were just not ready
yeah to absorb
you know we're not a sponge yet but or
or there's soil and those seeds get
planted and it just takes the right
environment for them to grow yeah so it
all grow a lot quicker yeah yeah maybe
they're just a it takes them a long time
to produce anything that's right I can't
tell you I told you to dinner last night
when I saw the success you're having
like my heart exploded in like uh like I
threw both my hands up in here I was
like yes I think I'm so anytime students
I've had the privilege of knowing that
it just makes my heart so full so man
congratulations and more importantly
you're not just like getting famous
you're actually helping people you're
handing people tools like oh man and I
think most of us think our marriages our
workplace our relationship with our kids
needs this Grand sweeping thing yeah it
usually doesn't usually it needs I'm
just gonna start doing this a little bit
different I'm gonna start doing this a
little bit differently I'm gonna
practice I feel myself about to say
something yeah first words are going to
breathe right I'm gonna practice that
yes and then you wake up two years later
and somebody says something to just and
your default setting is a smile right
and it's a total that's when you go oh
man yeah yeah I'm changing right yeah
I'm growing I'm changing I got a comment
not too long ago and I love this one
it's a it was a wife she was saying hey
I've been following your stuff for a
while and I was in an argument with my
husband it was very stubborn hard-headed
and we was knocked down drag out and she
said at the end
I took a breath and followed what you
said and I said I can do better
and she said
without a beat he said I can do better
too
he said never in any of our like 20
years of marriage has this man admitted
anything like that wow and it's just
like like what you said just was little
tweaks that's it it's usually the less
words the more impact that's right yeah
yeah that's awesome brother you're
awesome man congratulations thank you